first off keep their graphics as JPEGs
these are raster images they're taking
so keep them saved in a raster format
for the second question considering your
users are accessing your site on mobile
it's actually a good idea to inline
these images if you can inlining reduces
the number of requests the browser has
to make and requests are one of the
major contributors to laggy or
unperformed on mobile requests ad round
trips and round trips are one of the
biggest factors for slow websites on
mobile but with that being said in the
next lesson you'll see how in landing
images can limit your responsive options
so in the end an external files still
might be the way to go either answer is
correct